when the email arrived inviting me to
give this talk
and I saw that it was from Hillsdale
College it was as though talk radio had
come alive
um
I've been a huge listener to talk radio
since the early days of Rush Limbaugh
and Hillsdale has done a wonderful job
of getting its name out there in all
sorts of quite respectable ways and has
probably proved I think to be one of the
most Savvy users of Technology on the
conservative side so
when I saw that the topic was technology
itself
and it came from a place that I think
has used it savly and to everyone's
benefit I was a little crestfallen
because I have a very dark view of
technology and I wanted to fill you with
anxiety and Dread about
the future and even the present that you
may not be aware of
but in deference to hillsdale's
proficiency at using technology for good
I decided to turn it down
20 percent
I'm really a novelist by trade and a
Storyteller at heart
and so this may sound like a technical
uh and very high intellectual abstract
uh topic I'd like to tell it as a story
I'd like to tell you something about my
relationship to technology and what I've
learned about it as a journalist and as
a writer
and where I think we are now
and I'd like to give a little hope for
the future as the jaws of the giant
Beast clothes around us and we can still
see a bit of daylight
um
wandering around Hillsdale uh I saw
perhaps the best single quote uh on a
bronze plaque today uh with which to
start this speech it was Winston
Churchill who said engines were made for
men not men for engines
and that was spoken in 1946 in Miami I
never knew he hung out in Miami but I
guess as soon as the lights came on and
London he got himself to a warm place to
recoup
um
the truth is that though engines maybe
were made for men
it is not any longer the caves that we
are in control in fact we're not and I'm
going to start with a tiny demonstration
before I go into the storytelling mode
look at this thing
how many of you carrying this around
have thought twice about what you say to
a loved one
how many of you using it have
caught yourself making a text message or
an email and thought maybe I won't send
that
how many of you have late at night maybe
wondered if you should leave it on in
the same room in which you're having a
intimate conversation with a family
member
raise your hands anyone
well good at least you're honest some of
you because I'd warrant that most of you
if you have one have had these thoughts
I know as a journalist my practice has
been deeply impacted by
the fact that I have a spy in the room
at all times when I have this phone
not only a spy
that listens but one that can see me you
know if you follow the The Fortunes of
tick tock the Chinese uh infiltration
mechanism that is taking over the Youth
of America you know that
it actually
um triggers the camera the front-facing
camera in your phone to gauge your
reaction to certain stories in other
words it can look at you after you have
taken in some outrageous video
I don't know what and I don't want to go
into it now if you don't
um
and it will assess whether or not you're
pleased angry
um enticed whatever
that phone can do things that you don't
want to know
it can measure your steps as you know
but it can also
ping your location at every point I I I
I will give you uh an example I met as a
journalist not long ago with someone who
uh wanted to meet me privately
and uh we decided to do it without our
phones we both took them out of our
pockets and went to another place
but within an hour
and this is a little complicated to
explain within an hour our social media
revealed that we had been together
um it made recommendations to us at the
same time that came from a uh uh a store
that we'd been near
and it revealed in fact that you know
we'd been followed the whole time our
meeting was not confidential so anybody
who has this phone on them right now or
carries it with them in the course of
their daily lives is basically a
prisoner with an ankle bracelet but not
an ankle bracelet that just alerts the
police if you go outside a certain
perimeter but which listens looks
analyzes
does physiological studies
relays location
keep search histories analyzes search
histories for ideological uh themes
among others it doesn't just Market you
to uh you know Amazon or some other
company that wants to sell you something
it markets you to political
consultancies and to uh
all sorts of shadowy organizations here
and abroad that wish to influence
manipulate record track
even punish your behavior we've all
gotten used to it
I haven't heard a single person
sort of exclaim and panic as I've listed
these set of dire
capabilities
you're all used to it so am I I brought
it up with me
but it wasn't always this way
and
I'm going to tell you the story of my
sort of journey into this sort of Heart
of Darkness and and why I think
we still have a chance to sort of escape
a certain fate that I think is being
planned for us
in 2014 uh I was hired by the Atlantic
magazine to write about surveillance a
topic I knew very little about
because those who surveil us don't
publish their plans
it is the nature of spying on people
that they not be aware of it
there are some reasons to keep us aware
of it if they want to inhibit us or you
know sort of control our movements uh we
all know that in January 6th many of the
arrests were made using cell phone data
location uh if you were in Washington
and you were in a certain perimeter of
the capital and you had your cell phone
on you the FBI came to you that's
absolutely how it worked
um but in general they don't like you to
know their capabilities whether they're
law enforcement or major corporations so
when I set out to do this story I had
very few leads
um and I thought how am I going to draw
people into this surveillance issue uh
when the people who are conducting it
won't talk to me when the companies that
have perfected it keep it as a trade
secret
so I thought I will go down to this new
building in Utah the NSA Data Center
which is a building that had just gone
up in the suburbs of Salt Lake City on
the edge of a National Guard base it was
a big black box no windows with a
perimeter of barbed wire and a sort of
phosphorus pink
scary lights and
I know that inside that thing
because I've done research is every
phone call I've ever made
every picture I've ever taken every
search history I've ever generated on
any machine
my property is inside that locked
government
Vault and I'm going to go as close as I
can to its perimeter and see what
happens because at least I'll have a
kind of Moby Dick style beginning for my
story trying to get into the big locked
vault in which all of our data is stored
so I went with a veteran a kind of uh
Intrepid kid who had gotten kicked out
of the Navy
for high-spirited behavior and we
dressed all in black and we picked a a
night with a new moon
it was the middle of the winter January
the snow was deep we parked our car on a
side street
near Bluffdale Utah
a kind of prefab new neighborhood which
had been built for employees of the NSA
Data Center
and at about
9 30 at night in pitch black darkness we
set out through the snow to try to get
to the thing and see what happened
well we walked and we walked I'm gonna I
those of you who have paranoid fantasies
are going to be so delighted by what
happens next
we walked and we walked through the snow
post hauling as they call it you know in
snowy places snow up to our hips
getting closer and closer to this
phosphorescent gleaming dark
monolith on the horizon
and the thing about the NSA data center
that immediately strikes you when you
approach it physically is that it's
about the size of a average cities
shopping mall
and in it are contained not just every
digital record known to man that exists
the capacity to store 30 more years of
them we're talking about every book
every letter every photo every movie
every conversation
all of it can be contained in a space
that is smaller than a mall
three quarters of that space being
Refrigeration uh and air conditioning
technology to keep the servers cool
so it's as though the entire mind of
mankind and the entire output of our
brains
really fits
been something like this Auditorium
finally
that is a humiliating
vision of Mankind's Collective output
not since you know not since medieval or
Renaissance astronomers proved that
indeed this you know the universe and
the solar system didn't
go around the earth have have we had
such a uh
how can I put it humiliating uh image of
our own importance in the universe
the information age and the storage of
information allows us to literally gaze
upon the entirety of our whole project
and you know
see it with one glance
it's in there somewhere
what tiny fraction of that was mine I
can't even imagine
what tiny fraction of it was my towns I
would have hardly showed up on a pencil
point I'm sure
and as we walked closer and closer to
this thing I got literally scared I felt
like I was some sort of
um
epic Adventurer coming Upon a Monster
ah it was a monster that didn't blink it
was a monster that couldn't see it was a
monster that
had no Humanity whatsoever it was
gleaming and inside it was very very
cold to keep those servers from
overheating
but it was as though I was approaching
the black pit of Hell and my friend who
I was walking with was having the same
experience we were having an intense
emotional experience to a machine
as we got closer to it the moon kind of
came out
a little bit
and suddenly was blocked out by a dark
craft
now anybody here who knows something of
advanced military craft can probably
name what it was but we couldn't at the
time it was a silent
hovering
obvious you know military aircraft that
came out over the hillsides from the
National Guard base and hovered over us
as we stood about the distance I am from
those doors to the fence of this thing
and it hovered over us silently it's
only uh signature being a tiny red bead
a red bead of light like a cigarette
Ember almost
and then after having spooked us for
three or four minutes
It glided Off
now that was worth the whole trip to
know that you know indeed the black
helicopters the drones whatever that may
have been are active and absolutely
quiet and you know deadly to our enemies
that that was worth it